faut vraiment qu'on travaille sur ton
vol plané en solo moudre croque mort et
ben ben bouhout alors tu en prends ça
alors on fait moins
ouais c'est ça tu ferais jamais de mal
en unissant ça c'est beurk
ici la vie est géniale avant les dragons
poser quelques petits problèmes mais
aujourd'hui sont venus vivre avec toi je
t'ai dit à quel point tu es belle
aujourd'hui
non c est depuis que les vikings se
gausse des dragons
le monde est devenu encore plus vaste
sait-on génial
qu'est ce qui s'est passé qu'est ce qui
a pu faire ça
tu croit tout savoir sur les draps
bauges paris
voilà un aperçu de ce que tu ne sais pas
je vous connais non tu n'étais encore
qu'un bébé mais une mère n'oublie jamais
incroyable
tu les recrues
quelque chose se prépare quelque chose
que tu n'as jamais affronté maintenant
les dragons sont à moi
de notre peuple à settat destinée
ce que tu cherches et la de temps
geffroy et donges où l'on attend c'est
une blague
il
à
avec au bout
dragons et vikings redevenir et nuit
mais tu sais que sa part pas au lavage